Everyone
in the order knew and Anakin Skywalker
few would live to see what he became
Anakin spoke highly of you.
have to do what's right,
regardless of our personal feelings.
by the end of the Clone Wars.
I walked away from him and the Jedi.
I could use the help.
Once a rebel.
Always a rebel.
In this war,
you'll face more than just droids
as your master
is my responsibility to prepare you.
I won't always be there
to look out for you.
Welcome back, everyone. It's Charlie.
This is the way there's a bunch of trailer
footage for Ahsoka Episode 3 and B on
some of this footage is from later
episodes.
They've been teasing a bunch of references
and Easter eggs like Anakin Skywalker,
this new mystery galaxy.
I know there's a lot of questions
about that. So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We're still doing the Star Wars
Echo dot giveaway to name a new winner
during this video.
if for some reason
it feels like YouTube isn't
showing you my Ahsoka videos,
just watch a couple of my Ahsoka Episodes
like my episode
1 and Episode 2 video.
It should let YouTube know that you
actually want to see those new episodes.
And careful for spoilers from Episode 2
if you haven't seen it yet.
But the biggest new things
that they've teased so far are Thrawn.
And maybe Ezra too, being in a
totally different galaxy than we thought,
instead of just the unknown regions,
which is basically what the Star Wars
people Dave Filoni said after Rebels
Season 4.
before they started airing Ahsoka
episodes, Dave Filoni did say that
they changed a couple of things
about the backstory.
They retuned a couple of things,
and one of the big ones is them
being in a completely different galaxy,
not just in another
part of the main galaxy.
I know there are a lot of new time
travel theories too, because of what
Morgan Elsbeth said, this new Inquisitor
character still being a version of Ezra.
Even if the Space Rebels
like the purrgils, took Ezra
to the other galaxy with them all
explained all the Ezra time
travel theories in a second,
the truth might wind up being way simpler.
Don't be surprised if it is.
Usually when it comes to fan theories,
even if they're partially correct,
the actual explanation
that Dave Filoni, Jon Favreau have gone
with on The Mandalorian so far,
maybe it's okay to winds up being way, way
less complicated
Jon Favreau said a couple of funny things
about this before the Mandalorian Season
3 came out earlier this year,
He said the hardcore fans the past couple
of years of The Mandalorian since season
one usually come up with way
more interesting ideas
about the character, relationships,
the backstories
than they ever considered
in the writers room.
like a lot of
the fans are thinking about characters
in ways that they did not think
about in the writers room.
Like, Oh,
we didn't think about these relationships
between like Grogu, the Mandalorians,
what was going on with Moff Gideon
all these years,
mostly when it comes to the grittier
details of the series, like the background
stuff, like what was it really going on
with the Grogu Jedi cloning plot?
What was really going on with Doctor
Pershing Elia Kane this whole time?
Who wound up saving Grogu during order 66.
there were so many theories
that were way more complicated and way
deeper than what
they actually explained during the series.
So if you got a crazy theory
about what's happening on Ahsoka right now,
even if it's not totally correct,
you're probably not too far off
and you probably thought about it way
more than they actually thought about it
in the writers room.
The exception with the soldier,
though, is that there is a lot of details
that you need to have watched Star Wars
Rebels
and the Clone Wars to actually understand.
Don't worry,
if you didn't watch all those animated
episodes, I'll be explaining Easter eggs
and references in the background
as we go along in episodes.
It won't be quite as crazy as it sounds,
they use a bunch more Anakin Skywalker
references
in the trailer for upcoming episodes,
and if it wasn't clear,
they mix some older footage of Anakin
from previous series
like the Obi-Wan Kenobi flashbacks in
for Revenge of the Sith.
But his dialog is brand
new dialog that Hayden Christensen
recorded for the Ahsoka episode
So it is like brand new.
Hayden Christensen Cameos and stuff
A lot of people were confused by this
when they saw some of the trailer footage.
It's not Matt Lander's animated Anakin
Skywalker voice from the Clone Wars
or Tales of the Jedi
or even the Rebel series in Matt Lanter
only did a little bit of his antic and
voice for rebels.
Most of his stuff is from Clone Wars
and a little bit from Tales of the Jedi.
we only heard Anakin Skywalker voice
two times during rebels one when Ahsoka
sort of kept
visions of Anakin Skywalker
and remember him and sort of figure out
that he had turned into Darth Vader
because he still didn't know
that he had become
Darth Vader at the beginning of rebels.
then again during rebels season two
in Twilight of The Apprentice,
when they had their first in-person
reunion
since the events of Revenge of the Sith
and him becoming Darth Vader,
his breathing
mass got damaged in their fight, So.
She was able to hear his
and again voice through his mask
so all the dialog of
and giving a Ahsoka a training pep
talk is meant to be totally new dialog.
Hayden Christensen recorded and it's
meant to take place early in his days
as her master during the Clone Wars.
Like before, The Clone Wars
really ramps up.
the best comparison would be a scene
similar to the Tales of the Jedi episode,
where he trains her
with the help of the other clones.
she's still kind of learning her
lightsaber combat techniques
and how to fight multiple people
at the same time with her two lightsaber.
That was my during episode one.
In Episode 2,
like the much older version of Ahsoka,
during both of her fights,
they put her up against multiple targets
first a bunch of HK droids,
then the HK droids in Marrok,
what they might have done
is have any Skywalker flashbacks
when associates are training Sabine again
in lightsaber combat on her ship.
Like there's a bunch of footage of that.
Maybe that's when she starts
remembering her training lessons with
and again and throughout the series
they might just have more flashbacks
of her remembering.
And again,
maybe she'll also have a flashback to her
fight with him as Darth Vader, too,
just to address her trauma,
because they keep referencing
that during the first couple of episodes
that she still has
all this unresolved trauma.
Let me know in the comments
what kind of Anakin Skywalker
or Darth Vader cameo scenes
do you think we're going to actually see
on the series as Boomerang?
Just address all the crazy theories
about who he really is.
In everything that Dave
Filoni and Lucasfilm have said so far
about the Marrok character
could be them just misdirecting everyone.
Like we just want him to feel mysterious.
That's why he's wearing the face
mask, the armor this whole time.
the official synopsis for Marrok
is that he was a former inquisitor
and after the fall of the Empire,
the inquisitor was disbanded
or were hunted down by the New Republic.
And he just survived
by becoming a mercenary in the outer rim,
the same way that Balan school did
after Order 66.
now that they're not lying
about who Marrok really is,
they could just be misleading
as his build.
The way his armor sits on him,
the way he walks around
just makes him seem like he's a dude.
But younger than Ahsoka.
the reason why you're probably seeing
a bunch of Ezra Bridger time
travel theories.
Talking about Marrok is because of what
Morgan Elsbeth said during Episode 2
when she said that her nicest her powers
and abilities in the force
allowed her to communicate
with run across galaxies,
but also across time,
like across time and space.
That's kind of a new interpretation,
like a new spin on the idea
of what Knight's
sister powers and abilities are.
They started to get into that
during the Clone Wars
because they're a relatively new creation
in the Star Wars canon at the time.
the whole idea is that Knight's sisters
tap into the force like they connected
the force in a completely different way
than the traditional Jedi
or even the Sith characters,
which is why all their powers
seem so different,
even though they're all drawing their
power from the same essential source.
That's why during Jedi Survivor, Jedi
Fallen Order, Merrin
Knight's sister powers are so different
from Callixtus says Powers
that's also why you're hearing her.
Listen to the voices of a bunch of knights
sisters through the force.
Like they can do that.
All nine sisters are able to do that.
the reason why time would be a factor
in her communicating
with Thrawn across galaxies
is because of real world relativity.
Just to get into the nitty gritty
like real world science.
What would happen if you actually could
travel to another galaxy in real life
the whole idea with time and space
relativity is the faster you travel like
the closer you get to the speed of light
and you enter hyperspace.
If you're talking about Star Wars
terminology,
the more time changes
relative to your speed,
like the passage of time slows for
you compared to everyone else.
Christopher Nolan kind of got into this
during the Interstellar movie,
or if you read
or you watch the Foundation series,
they have a lot of characters
aging at different speeds
because some of them travel vast
distances across space.
They enter cryo sleep,
so they stop the aging process.
So you end up with a whole bunch
of characters that age at different rates.
So on the Ahsoka series,
it's totally possible that time
passed differently for Thrawn and Ezra
while they're in the other galaxy than
it has for everyone in the main galaxy
like Ahsoka morgan,
Elsbeth, Luke Skywalker, Grogu,
The Mandalorian, everybody.
So for all the regular characters,
it might seem like it's been years
since Ezra in Thrawn disappeared,
but it might seem like for them
they've only gone just a little while.
no. On the flip side of that,
to get to the whole mark is Ezra theories
that everybody sees spinning around
mirror, could be a version of Ezra
from way later in his timeline,
like something happened to him,
Morgan Elsbeth was able to use her nice
sister Powers to twist him,
make him serve them in somehow
time for him has passed differently,
so it's a much older version of him.
So like, enough
time went by for this to happen to him.
so even though it seems like he may have
been twisted, it happened a long time ago
for this particular character,
even though for the main characters,
they think that Ezra is still been lost
for years.
like if Ezra winds up
being a version of Burak, it's possible
that he, at some point in his past,
already made it back
from that other galaxy
in so much more time passed for him.
like I said, the real explanation for whom
Iraq is will probably be way,
way simpler.
So don't be surprised if it is not Ezra.
But that just kind of addresses the whole.
Ezra has been right in front of us
the whole time.
Kind of think like, are they going to wait
till the very end of this series
to reveal Ezra Bridger in live action?
Or are we going to see him way
before that?
Like, are we seeing him right now?
Don't be surprised
if there is a twist behind Ezra.
Just in general.
the way that Dave Filoni talked
about Thrawn coming back, though,
like this whole new star War
that they're planning on having
against the New Republic
in the Thrawn movie.
it sounds like they're timing.
MORGAN Elizabeth's plan
here with the eye of Scion trying to jump
his entire fleet back through hyperspace
at the actual end of the series,
like the last couple of episodes will be
when he actually comes back
to the main galaxy
And they'll be some moment
at the end of the series
where he's fully back with the whole fleet
and starts calling out orders,
rallying for the remaining factions
of the Shadow Council to come to him.
Or they cue up some galactic Skype
session,
like during The Mandalorian
with the other leaders,
that was kind of what they were teasing.
During the Mandalorian season
three, Episode seven,
Then they'll probably just continue
to tease that out
during the Mandalorian season four.
Like them massing in the background
in the conflict beginning,
what would the actual war like the full on
battle beginning in Thrawn movie.
right now, the next few episodes
will be Ahsoka, The others learning what
Morgan, Elsbeth and Balin Scholes
real plans are in the whole idea
is that balance
school has this completely separate
agenda from what
Morgan Elsbeth wants with Thrawn.
like, he's just helping them
because the enemy of my enemy is my friend
kind of situation.
He has a completely separate plan.
and it looks like there are going to be
a couple really big fights, couple of big
rematches
on this planet with the waypoint,
But if you spot any other Easter eggs
in the footage, the trailer that I didn't
talk about in the video right down
below in the comments, my full Episode
three video will post next week
after they release it Congratulations.
Finesse Is Back 2948
You're the giveaway winner
from my last big Star Wars giveaway.
Please email me
on the about page of my channel on desktop
so I can get your contact details.
click here for my Ahsoka Episode
2 video and click here
for all my Ahsoka episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe. And this is the way!